back in the 1980s powerless distributing  processing books came out they had most  of the stuff in it back then what's your  take on the roadblocks the most  important roadblocks apart from maybe  funding I think fundamentally I mean  they're they're well known as  limitations is that they're really  inefficient at learning and they're not  so they're really good at extracting  representations from raw data but not  good at learning knowledge bases of like  accumulating knowledge over time that  that's the fundamental limitation i  expert systems are really good at  accumulating knowledge but very bad at  doing that in an automated way symbolic  AI so I don't know how to overcome a lot  of people say there's hybrid approaches  I believe more data bigger networks and  better selection of data will take us a  lot farther  you